[Musique]
1986 quatre renaud barrault lesigne
jean marais 72 ans interprète dont bing
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cruel souvenir de ma gloire passée
brûlé temps de jeu
en ajout est fâché
faisons un geste à la sensibilité
exacerbée tout en puissance et en
fragilité jean marais dont la vocation
était de jouer s'offrait une nouvelle
fois se parle à son public depuis
longtemps déjà il avait pris place dans
la légende saltimbanques de génie aux
dons multiples jean marais dont françois
chalais disait joliment il ne vieillit
pas il accumule des jeunesses excessive
est partie sans pour autant nous qu il
nous reste l'image d'un homme chaleureux
courageux fier indépendant
il y avait besoin de solitude comme
d'autres de soleil et qui lorsque par
aventure il se retrouvait seul avec
lui-même se demandait sans doute
pourquoi sa vie n'était somme toute
qu'une suite de bonheur et de chance une
injustice permanente plaisante était une
vie commencé modestement dans un
quartier populaire de cherbourg j'étais
un vrai monstre à visage d'ange dira
plus tard l'acteur un monstre à visage
d'ange il ne tardera pas à devenir un
monstre sacré
[Musique]
1913 n'était certes pas une bonne année
pour venir au monde la guerre n'allait
pas tarder à briser le cocon familial le
père de jean ébranlé ne s'en remit
jamais cette photo d'un bonheur bientôt
anéanti gens là conservera pieusement
tout comme la photo de sa mère qu'il
aimait tant et de son frère aîné henri
dont il était si proche comme dans l'un
des nombreux mails au conte se
complaisait à produire à l'époque la
mère de gens avaient une double vie elle
était kleptomane
ainsi qu'on peut le voir cette
singularité n'empêcha pas l'enfant
terrible de grandir
il était bagarreur hâbleur et pour tout
dire difficile
[Musique]
adolescent déjà passionné de cinéma il
s'enflammait aux exploits de pearl white
qui le fascinait plus tard quand il a
pris avec la déception qu'on imagine que
son idole n'exécutait pas elle même ses
cascades
il décidera de ne jamais se faire
doubler lorsqu'il aurait à tourner des
séquences dangereux
[Musique]
on prétend que l'enfant terrible autret
d'adonis se garda bien jusqu'à son 85e
anniversaire de discerner fiction et
réalité et ainsi il n'entend 10 points
siffler la fin de la récréation mais
comme il aimait à le dire il faut
s'accepter tel qu'on vous croit
[Musique]
la chance de jean marais date de 1937 et
de sa rencontre avec jean cocteau quatre
années auparavant il avait entendu
parler pour la première fois de l'auteur
de la machine infernale dans de bien
troublante circonstances on connaît
d'anecdotes nous sommes en 1933 un ami
peintre l'invite à passer le voir
stupéfait il découvre alors chez son ami
le portrait d'un visage en tout point
semblable au sien
l'oeuvre est signée jean cocteau dont le
film le sens du poète a confirmé les
évidentes qualités de cinéaste
[Musique]
depuis ce jour jean marin qui ignorait
tout de jean cocteau
c'était bien promis de faire sa
connaissance bien lui en prit car qui
pourrait encore l'ignorer l'ascendant
spirituel du poète façonnera pour
l'éternité
l'immensité de l'acteur jusqu'à en faire
un mythe
[Musique]
bien qu'ils donnent parfois l'impression
d'en sourire ne disait il pas le coq
tour me voyais toutes les qualités et 7
et son seul défaut jean marais se
souviendra toujours que jean cocteau lui
tendit la main à une époque où je nomme
ardent mais en des princes il brûlait
des tanches et son infinie soif d'amour
et de tendresse
[Musique]
au fond je considère je suis né en 1937
en réalité chouinard miel entre elles
mais je suis né quand j'ai rencontré
jean gautheron puisque c'est lui qui m'a
créé complètement jean marais qui
n'aspire à jamais à la postérité
s'apprête alors à entrer dans
l'immortalité
jusqu à ce qu une impitoyable nouvelle
vague menace de le submerger
il tournera film se fait
son meilleur rôle
le sien celui d'un homme rare qui au fil
du temps s'imposera comme l'un des plus
talentueux serviteur du théâtre et du
cinéma
seul ou presque jean cocteau savait que
celui qu'on surnommait le prince des
comédiens allait devenir le roi 1 a
longtemps j'ai lutté contre lui
qu'il usait de la peine en disant je
m'en veux beaucoup
j'avais peur en me laissant dirigé par
cocteau de devenir une espèce de
mécanismes de cocteau de deux pions de
cocteau et de ne plus avoir rien faire
par moi-même et j'ai lutté contre ces
indications et un jour je lui dis
maintenant je me sens assez fort pour me
laisser diriger par tous les films que
j'ai tournés avec octo m'ont marqué jean
cocteau disait que dans l'histoire de la
littérature y avait que deux grands
romans d'amour c'était roméo et juliette
et tristan et isolde et on m'a proposé
d'écrire à tristan et zulte moderne qui
est l éternel retour et du jour au
lendemain
ça a été extraordinaire parce que
j'avais propositions sur proposition
c'était mal à ma chance fait
l'éternel retour ce sont son premier
grand rôle ils ont même c'est son
premier rôle et ça lui a collé à la peau
parce que c'est ce même c'était pendant
la guerre moi j'étais pas là mais
c'était pas mal la guerre il paraît que
ça avait fait un triomphe il portait un
pull jacquard et que
tous les garçons de l'époque on portait
un pull jacquard c'était la beauté sur
terre il faut dire la vérité c'était une
statue grecque
il était très très beau et j'ai compris
qu'on puisse tourner bout il était
vraiment sincère ni jésus certaine
gueule et bien sûr mon pas beau parce
que pour lui à cause de son âge il avait
presque de la définition romantique de
la génération d'acteurs d'abord lui où
ils ressemblent tous un peu à charles
boyer où je dirais qu'avec jean pierre
aux mots jean a été un des premiers
jeunes premiers authentique il avait
l'âge du rôle ce qui était vraiment
absolument une révolution alors ce qui
impliquait aussi bien que l'on invente
des films qui ne soit pas l'éternel
roman d'amour où la jeune première qui
n'était pas une première
se tue à la fin il fallait inventer un
autre cinéma
jeffrey bon souvenir de lui le tout
première quand j'avais 17 ans et kate et
que tout à coup j'ai vu apparaître ce
dieu vivant pour moi c'était un dieu
vivant
je suis d'une famille qui n'avait pas
beaucoup d'argent et je me souviens qu'à
noël tout de suite après la guerre mon
cadeau de noël qu'avait pu me faire ma
mère c'était deux oranges et m'amener
voir la belle et la bête au cinéma de
tellement cadeaux de noël
donc j'ai ce souvenir dont et tout à
coup je voi je vois je vois arriver le
prince devant moi récemment plus beaux
jours
[Musique]
leur choix quand j'te dis
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui la belle cocteau acceptait ce
premier grand film
c'est à la libération
mais il s'était bien entouré il y avait
rené clément qui était premier assistant
il y avait georges auric qui avait fait
la musique des rares qui avaient fait
les costumes et pour l'anecdote les
costumes à l'époque bérard ses dires qui
faisait l'écho ce type c'est pierre
cardin qui couvait les costumes et comme
cardin avait à peu près la même carrure
que marais il essayait les costumes il
était le il était le mannequin cardin
était le mannequin de jean marais
c'était très douloureux pour lui parce
qu'il a fait une allergie aux tous les
poils vont lui mettait sur son visage et
bizarrement cocteau au même moment afin
une allergie aussi par amour
j'ai réussi en ce sens que j'ai presque
toujours fait ce que j'avais envie de
faire écrire à jean marin consacré en
1943 par l'éternel retour notre futur
jeune femme y avait toutes les raisons
de se montrer confiant dans son avenir
déjà l'auteur d' orphée en parlera plus
tard il court plus vite que son âge s'en
éloigner pour autant du théâtre il ne
cessera sa vie durant de servir sans
jamais se servir
jean marais se donnent à leur corps et
âme au septième heure idolâtré par à
jean cocteau dont la réputation est de
donner des forces à ce qu'il aime
les parents terribles en 1948 le
rapprocheront yvonne debreu qu'il
considérera définitivement comme sa
seconde mais
[Musique]
les parents terribles quand j'ai créé le
fils en 1938
j'ai dit à jean comme souvent quand je
serai plus âgés je jouais le père et il
était d'accord
ah ça c'est le film est assez
extraordinaire à l'époque
à l'époque il y avait des des magazines
comme ça qu'ils étaient des des romans
films fait avec les avec les photos du
film
je ne sais pas si ça existe encore mais
c'était fantastique
c'est extraordinaire mais c'étaient des
époques vraiment très intéressante parce
que par exemple un film à la première
d'un film on distribuait faut aux
invités aux spectateurs des très bons
fascicule comme cela pour la belle et la
bête alors il s'était vraiment très
élégant et les très jolies une photo
comme celle ci je trouve ça un
chef-d'oeuvre
c'est une photo fantastique il y à
l'oeil uniquement l'oeil 2000 à paris
il a parlé j'ai failli me clusan est
faite aux plus jeunes
on est resté très très bons amis
l'année précédente au théâtre comme au
cinéma l'aigle à deux têtes dont chaque
phrase sonne comme une parabole
amoureuse
un film d'une élégante aussi vrai que
raffiné écrire à la vedette avait
défrayé la chronique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les marchés
donc je devrais votée cet automne benoît
launay
[Applaudissements]
posez votre tête sur mes genoux
in the pet le rêve d'un dans meurs qui
dort c'est profondément tu ne sais même
pas si les rêves
c'est un texte magnifique où je voudrais
pas interpréter cocteau mon seul usage
ou à travers un argument prétendu
historique
il n'y a que les deux êtres qui ont
premier coup d'oeil ce sont retenus ils
s'échappent non plus et quand on pense
que les deux s était jean marais et
d'huissiers hier c'était alors la pièce
est peut-être pas absolument
chef-d'oeuvre mais était très théâtre
avec les costumes d'époque magnifique
avec la la tout y était confidente le
traître du répertoire tout y était et
puis il y avait ce pour quoi on se
devait enlever la chute de gens qui se
laissait tomber sur le dos sur un bon
étage on entendait sa tête qui cognait à
chaque marche absolument fautes elles
n'étaient pas truqués
tous les soirs tout le soir
dans cet habitat
[Musique]
il ya deux joué au théâtre tous les
emplois possibles
je pense quelle admirable il ne pense
jamais que rien des terres qu'il fallait
toujours aller plus loin palanquin jean
marais voulait faire les équipages du
grand ancien
les prises de vue du masque de fer le
dernier film qu'il a tourné sous la
direction d'henri decoin illustre bien
le parti pic à jean marais de jouer le
jeu dans ses moindres détails puisqu'il
refuse de se faire doubler par des
cascadeurs professionnels
d'artagnan a eu bien des interprètes
mais à travers le héros d'alexandre
dumas jean marais a créé un personnage
de cape et d'épée qui à l'instar de
fanfan la tulipe ignorent les dangers et
les risques pour le quark à la fantaisie
mais c'était peut-être là le vrai
caractère du seigneur de bahts
gentilhomme gascon et officiers de
fortune
si j'accepte de prendre des risques
c'est d'abord parce que ça m'amuse et
ensuite parce que si on accepte un rôle
où il y à des risques il est normal de
les prendre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais vous ne faites jamais de sport non
je fais jamais de sport j'ai horreur du
sport j'ai horreur du moindre mouvement
de culture physique je n'aime pas ça du
tout c'est à dire que je pense que mon
destin ayant toujours été très gentil
pour moi mon destin dû se dire il
commence à devenir vieux ce pour marais
il faut lui envoyer des rôles où il ya
du sport de façon à ce qu'il remue dans
son métier puisqu'il ne remet pas dans
la vie
[Musique]
lang d'une seule parole vous n'avez pas
le droit de condamner votre roi sans
écouter sa défense ont reçu est ce votre
roi qui vous a donné l'ordre de vous
rendre notre assemblée pour tenter de
nous rallier à sa cause
que reprochez vous au roi d'être encore
très jeune lutter seul contre tous le
capitan volant au secours de son world à
angers
[Musique]
un siècle avant que jean marc n y
rencontrer jean cocteau rudolph et au
père écrivait dans voyage au zig zag si
dommage que le danger soit chose au fond
si dangereuse
sans quoi on s'y jette pas et rien que
pour éprouver cette joie puissant ce
reconnaissante élan du coeur qui
accompagne la délivrance
alors on s'interroge en prenant tous les
risques
toute sa vie en toutes circonstances
flirtant avec l'amour comme avec ta mort
jean marais ne sollicitait il pas tout
simplement en permanence les landes un
coeur il ne demandait qu'à bas qu'au
plus fort que les eaux jusqu'à la
délivrance qui leur assurant apaiser son
angoisse n'affirmait-il part il fait
toujours bon d'obéir à son coeur
c'est un signe de vie avant d'ajouter
faussement désinvolte je n'ai pas peur
de la mort au contraire j'aimerais bien
le voir mourir pour savoir si tu es bien
jouer toutes les morts à l'étranger ne
m'entraîne pas et en général je ne
répète pas non plus tout ce qui est
dangereux je ne répète pas c'est en
général il y à un spécialiste que l'on
fait venir et qui répète pour moi et je
le regarde attentivement
il me donne des conseils
je vois d'après ce qu'il fait le danger
à éviter et en général je le fais du
premier coup et on tourne à trois ou
quatre appareils pour m'éviter de
recommencer plusieurs fois les prises
avec quelle sincérité l'artiste aux
mille talents le créateur surdoué est il
parvenu à se réaliser lui-même jusqu'à
l'extrême comme il le fit dans phantom
ans est la première fois que je suis
double est véritablement dans dans ce
film de fantômes à ce cas il y avait
effectivement de la chute libre à faire
il ne s'agit plus du goût du risque là
il s'agit de nuit de la bonne volonté il
s'agit d'une technique et d'une science
que je ne possédais pas et donc il a
fallu que gilles de la main me remplace
pour la voix chute libre
[Musique]
pour le crochet ici très bien et bien
écoutez si tu veux tu vas le passé mais
tu à l'endosser on va te régule fidak
corps
alors
il est pas mal et un petit peu consommé
elle est courte elle est courte on à
l'aller s'est fait l'écho en question de
sortie ménages français a très bien
belles surprises alors le par le vent
relatif à la sortie on va te larguer à
70 miles points 110 km heure quand tu es
jamais tes deux pieds ici qui prend bien
çà comme çà et là tu vas commencer à
avoir le vent en relatif alors là tu
mets ta deuxièmement ici et tu passes en
position ici on est bien comme ça tu
regardes bien devant toi tu t'es un
coupé comme ça et là comme ça on
comprend bien un terrain immédiatement
là je pense car ils ont deux jambes bien
à la rive est bien tes jambes en arrière
je sais c'est d'accord va commencer à
faire du vent oui je dois ce grand jeu
mais là tu viendras et du coup déjà les
gens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'exception confirmant parfois
dramatiquement la règle la seule fois où
en 1966 au cours du tournage du film de
christian jacq lesaint prend là fut jean
marais acceptera de se laisser doubler
par gilles de la main le véhicule que
conduisait le cascadeur fit une
spectaculaire embardée puis plusieurs
tonneaux
gilles de la marque qui jusqu'à ce jour
fatal avait triomphé de centaines de
situation beaucoup plus dangereuse ou ne
survécut points à ses blessures
à
il savait qu'il avait quelqu'un aussi un
bon vieux quoi sinon il n'aurait pas
pris tous les risques et donc qui se
croyait donc un vénérable jean cocteau
est mort il a dit je vais faire semblant
de continuer à vivre et je crois qu'à
partir de ce moment là il a été plus
fragiles tant qu'elle cocteau là il
était vraiment un chevalier qui
combattait les dragons après il était
plus fragile
[Musique]
souvenirs
site ynet
[Musique]
un souvenir
cassou
lee
kasso
à nîmes
ok
e
tant souffrir
c'était un exemple extraordinaire pour
moi j'essayais de lui ressemble pas lui
ressembler parce que il est à des
auteurs qu'on ne peut jamais atteindre
mais en essayant de s'élever à son
niveau on reste un peu moins barque en
serait restée normalement gens je n'ai
jamais rien fait dans ma vie sans penser
qu'ils soient là ou qu'ils ne soient pas
là sans penser qu'en penserait gens
qu'est-ce qui le diraient ce qu'ils
approuveraient ce qu'il serait content
ce qu'ils soient fiers de moi et
pour moi il n'est pas mort parce que je
continuerai à penser à son jugement et
il continuera à me diriger
on se dit vraiment moi moi je n'ai pas
connu coq touré mais d'après quand jean
racontez pas ce qui se passait pas un
jour sans qu'ils parlent pas de coke
d'euros toujours est il toujours quelque
chose qui l'a ramenée à cocteau c'est
vrai que ça a été de quelque chose sur
mon profond voilà tout tourner un petit
peu toujours autour de sept univers de
jean cocteau de son oeuvre
il est lui-même lui même en interne
était imprégné il jouait toujours du
cocteau même quand il jouait tout à fait
autre chose
moi je ne suis pas du tout une
professionnelle mais du tout mais
j'adore le terme
j'ai le mal rouge et or comme des
cocteau ce qu'on peut trouver plus joli
et comme cocteau j'ai connu les jeudis
après-midi au châtelet on se disait marc
gascon et d sera rentré parce que face à
lyon rentre donc il y avait ça qui nous
unit c'est beaucoup ce n'était pas une
professionnelle
j'étais le bon public et puis en plus
j'avais comme comme lui ce goût du
théâtre
alors vous n'avez toujours des choses à
raconter
je lui disais ça fait toujours rire du
studio vous pouvez imposer des drôles de
charge pour jean cocteau
il fallait être dieu merci c'était dans
mon quartier rue de la gaieté pour
applaudir bacchus parce qu'il a été un
petit peu éreinté par un inventeur mais
il fallait te soutenir toit aux français
parce que tu te faisais en boîte et tous
les soirs parce que premièrement tu
jouais en vain costume c'est à dire ta
tunique ici vont avec
et ton petit manteau c'était que déjà
prodigieux mais surtout c'est toi bien
sûr c'était dans l'air d'accord mais
c'est toi qui a introduit une diction
normal
au lieu de dire elle sautait au mois
huit essentiel tu disais elle se tait au
moins limiter son silence alors il ya
des les sifflements qu'il y avait moi et
quelques autres de vue sur le ciel bravo
bravo bravo
quand on m'a demandé de rentrer la
comédie française
j'ai dit je veux bien une condition
c'est de monter britannicus j'ai monté
le spectacle
ce qui m'amuse c'est que là dans le sine
de certains critiques m'ont dit que
j'étais
classique que je jouais que la cie hors
jeu joue de la même façon que je jouais
britannicus en 1953 et à l'époque ne
pouvait passer des classiques
s'affairent pour épouvantable parce que
c'était la première fois qu'on parlait
le vert au mieux de chanter parce que
les acteurs à l'époque chanté beaucoup
et même dix fois celui et je montre aux
vit que pour cette infamie et le suis-je
blanchi pouvoir un jour jean marc est un
jeu ne se conduit pas commun comme un
seigneur il se conduit vraiment v laisse
même pas comme jean marais nous ça nous
émeut parce qu'on marais on l'a vu dans
les films le capitan le bossu fatou les
tous les films de cocteau et ou alors le
voir en chair et en os des fois avec les
les acteurs de la pièce on a
l'impression qu'on est nous mêmes
spectateurs de quelque chose qui se
passe on oublie complètement con est
qu'on est en train de jouer pendant les
répétitions il ya des moments où
s'arrêtait rose avait même plus et yano
je reconnais mon sens à cherbourg
massenet s'envoler en cette année sans
lien en vous bien non
je vous louiez vient si je jouais bien
je me suis jamais mais alors je veux pas
dire je jouais bien fait mais c'est une
chance dans la vie de de ne pas être
content de soi parce qu'on essaie de
faire des progrès et de devenir l'acteur
qu'on souhaiterait être finalement n'y
arrivent jamais bien sûr mais mais ça
donne un intérêt passionnant de la
carrière du métier moi j'évite de
prononcer le mot métier parce que parce
que je trouve que c'est pas un métier
une profession où on a tellement de
passion et de plaisir à à le faire que
j'appelle plus un métier un peu sa
distraction passion cc c'est
extraordinaire quand on me demande quels
conseils donnez vous un jeune peut faire
ce métier je dis d'abord ce que c'est la
passion de ce métier mais ça on peut pas
conseiller on l'a où on l'a pas mais ce
qu'on peut avoir qu on peut acquérir ces
l'autocritique d'être très sévères avec
soi-même plus sévère que tous les
critiques qui précédèrent que tout le
monde est comme ça on arrive à faire des
progrès j'ai appris ce que pouvait être
et il fera peut-être rire les esprits
malveillants
l'incroyable modestie je vous dis pour
l'avoir dès qu il ne croyais jamais que
c'était pour lui qu'on attendait ne
croyais jamais que c'était pour bon je
ne crois qu'il sait qu'il n'a jamais
réalisé à quel point il était quand même
elle est la vedette de notre époque quoi
je suis peut-être au en agence et mini
une image du côté public mais il me
semble qu'il n'a jamais jamais quel
petit nez il faisait du théâtre comme
comme on respire c'était brannens son
monde à lui me répétait il répétait
europe prenait son nom s'était jamais
c'est bien c'était mai
il était extraordinaire on ne pense pas
qu'ils n'auraient qu'il aurait pu ne pas
faire du théâtre c'était sa raison de
vivre
et puis leur autre chose houle a été
éblouissant il remplace sable et cetera
un sacha guitry pas rejoué depuis 50 ans
l'amour masqué gens dans sacha guitry
c'est parfois vraiment
et puisqu'on met à venir l'été
moi faire à moitié des choux
les monts
il
et moi aimons
mondino
le mondial
[Musique]
m
au premier acte
bon il ya un quiproquo une jeune fille
s'éprend d'un jeune homme dont elle a vu
la photo / comme un photographe
or cette coupe cette photo a été prise
trente ans auparavant alors elle finit
par rejoindre téléphoner au monsieur qui
arrive et elle dit oh mon dieu c'est son
père voyez bon c est à la fin de l'acte
l'acteur qui était donc jean marc elle
revient sur ses pas prend la photo qui
avait ajouté la gamine la regarde et dit
c'est vrai que j'étais bien lorsque
j'avais 20 ans rideau un tonnerre
d'applaudissements les gens me disant je
t'aime tu faisais une fois par semaine
ça qu'est ce qu'ils ont à applaudir
comme ça après le jeu mais j'ai entendu
à pour dire comme ça ce n'est qu'ils
voient pas de ses toits qu'ils
applaudissent et parce que leurs 20 ans
étaient les tiens c'était ton tricot
roja car l'éternel retour c'était s'est
ensuite encore toi fait mieux mais il
faut en prendre ton parti oui y met en
avant ne peut pas imaginer la modestie
qu'il avait tout au moins avec moi je
sais pas comment il était avec une série
ses collègues acteurs mais la modestie
professionnels qui l'avait si cette
crainte de ne pas faire assez bien mais
c'est pas possible nantis de travailler
travail est de toujours faire mieux il a
toujours été d'une conscience [__] est
la moindre des choses c'était vivement
il pouvait toujours est il n'approuvait
pas
vous pensez
[Musique]
à vallauris où des mimosas dispense
ainsi que l'écrit vie sully prudhomme
un parfum pénétrant comme un aveu
d'amour jean marais et toujours lent
omniprésent
[Applaudissements]
dans le jardin de sa magnifique
propriété désormais endormi on peut
marcher sur ses pas émues vont lui en
voudrait presque de nous avoir fait de
la peine
en nous quittant pendant 15 ans j'ai pas
tournée elle la légende disait alors tu
tournes plus jeunes ici je tourne mais
la terre
[Musique]
j'ai que douze ans que je fais de la
poterie
à l'étagé a fait construire ma maison
comme j'étais dans le midi pas loin de
vallauris j'ai décidé que j'allais
m'amuser à faire de la poterie
alors je suis allé je suis allé à la
halle aux richesses des jeunes marchands
de terre je lui dis je voudrais bien
senti la terre alors il m'a regardé un
peu étonné ma vie mais ce n'est pas me
faisiez de la poterie qui dit j'en fais
pas mais je commence des mains alors il
a ri et m'a dit vrai que vous preniez
des leçons au rejet du mouvement que ça
mais je connais personne à l'allumage et
vous présenter quelqu'un il m'a présenté
un jeune homme s'appelait monsieur
pascal idée m'a donné son et au bout de
six mois et manille on était devenus
copains et madix est ce que tu fais ça
ressemble pas ce que font les autres et
tu devrait ouvrir un magasin à vallauris
alors j'ai dit chiche dit j'ai ouvert un
magasin
ici on a pointé corner l'image du demi
dieu aux yeux lavande qui comme l'a si
joliment dit stéphane denis incarnait un
monde de rêve où les couronnes était de
cartons et les coeurs d'or
à l'espace marais où l'on apprend à le
mieux connaître on pressent que l'on
chanteur est un seul est surtout d'une
beauté intérieure
il exprima dans ses oeuvres avec tant de
sincérité d'authenticité de sensibilité
et de générosité que ses qualités
humaines contribuèrent à faire de lui un
être hors du commun
de son propre aveu peindre ou créer
était pour lui un acte d'amour car
c'était toujours un objet ou un être qui
l'aimaient qu'il fixait pour toujours
sur sa toile ou dans son heure
il travaillait le sénat mais sa tête les
conduisaient moins que son coeur dans le
silence de son atelier on entendait
parfois s'interroger pourquoi se
demandait-il bien des gens font-ils
l'impossible comparaître bout
physiquement
alors qu'il est au pouvoir de tous deux
lettres moralement
et que personne accomplit sa techno l'on
comprend bien ici pourquoi jean cocteau
disait jean marais il était son soleil
et que le feu brûlait dans son âme
[Musique]
c'est pas l'être qui disait je suis
content de moi liban il avait un goût du
perfectionnisme mais il n'avait jamais
été assez bien on aurait pu encore faire
mieux
du reste il dit lui même sur ce tableau
des oiseaux là il corrigeait il en
rajoutait s'était jamais fini pour lui
un tableau n'était jamais fini il y
avait toujours des choses a ajouté
bon bah même la dalle le talent d'un
grand acteur aussi à mon avis il ya deux
choses
il ya quand même une influence de
cocteau un certain moment ça c'est pour
le dessin à londres
il ya un très très nette à la cocteau
dans le reste dans toutes ses paysages
en particulier et dans toutes ces
oeuvres antérieures
c'est pas du tout une critique de ma
part en contre à cette admiration ya
quand même toujours cet attachement à
l'enfance il peignait des paysages d'un
petit peu de rêve tout est toujours
jolie dans ce qu'il fait si vous
regardez bien le dessin de jean marais
ses poteries c'est une âme d'enfant
il avait tous les talents il pouvait
dessiner il pouvait écrire il pouvait
peindre il avait tous les talents ce
gars et des talents qui devine qu'il a
acquis je veux dire il a appris tout
seul
maintenant il ya eu cocteau qui lui a
appris des choses je veux dire jean
marais apprenez tout ça si au théâtre
c'est au théâtre la lumière était pas
comme ils voulaient et puis que sa
colère parce qu'il s'occupait de tout
âge en théâtre s'occupait des lumières
s'occupait des décors il s'occupait du
tout où il avait le sens du beau par
exemple quand il a monté néron à la
comédie française
il est parti en tournée avant de monter
aqmi française avec une comédienne qui
avait un certain âge et qui joue et
agrippine il lui avait fait une robe
extraordinaire mais qui pesait 40 kg
mais c'était très beau c'est super
seulement la pauvre ne pouvais pas
bouger
[Musique]
il a jamais n'a jamais démordu a fallu
qu'elle garde la traîne jusqu'au bout
c'était un acteur c'était un peintre
c'était un dessinateur s'était
quelqu'un de généreux il faisait tout
toucher à tout et il était doué pour
tous
elle pas le seul vous savez le
l'occupation de nous que j'ai par le
théâtre et le cinéma me fait voir
beaucoup de monde et notre seul est un
est un vrai repos et j'apprécie la
solitude des fois j'ai six mois sans
retenir ici
[Musique]
vous avez vécu rien ne manque jamais et
que des êtres humains peut être que j'ai
perdu mais autrement
rien ne manque c'était tout de même un
solitaire et il aimait beaucoup qu'on ne
le dérange pas et à vallauris son
atelier de peinture sculpture poterie
étaient au rez-de-chaussée par le jardin
au sous sol dans la liaison et il y
passait vraiment ces journées seul pour
moi il était devenu comme mon frère
comme mon père comme quelqu'un que
j'avais toujours connu qui faisait
partie de la famille
il aimait plus offrir que on lui offre
mais pour offrir il était généreux il
vous offrait des choses qui à la
démesure à la démesure et pour lui qu'on
lui offre n'ont rien rien n'y faisait
plaisir
si vous lui disiez j'aime bien ce dessin
de bérard et bien vous donner le dessin
bérard ça c'est sûr
moi j'ai à la maison un traître très
joli vase qu'il avait acheté pour lui et
puis je les aurais dû jolie se valent
ils te plairait bien
j'ai hérité du jazz il me l'a donnée
tout de suite qu'il était d'une
générosité dans les cadeaux bons ils
m'avaient à dîner on dîne dans
l'excellent restaurant italien tout près
de chez lui et on m'appelle un taxi on a
passé une excellente soirée et jeudi va
la vie te coucher mon bon monsieur tu
commence tôt demain non j'attends de
taxi j'écoute genre nous sommes au
restaurant mais celle ci va arriver là
que tu veux qu'il m'arrive ta vie de sa
tante acti email dans taxi grosse bise
etc
j'arrive ici j'ai dit ok si monsieur je
vous dois combien monsieur marc aymes à
payer largement il voulait simplement
régler le taxi sans lui en aperçoit
c'est quand même des délicatesses qui
n'ont plus tellement cours de nos jours
han han
de lui téléphone peu près un an vend
seulement quand elle m'a dit que c'est
drôle écoute en te parlant je suis en
train de lui dans l'atelier
je suis en train de dessiner comme
souvent des petits angelots et voilà
quand tu parles que le parent noir j'ai
fait des petits anges noirs
ah ben je vais mettre du rouveau tour je
ne peux pas vous dire l'impression
d'être funeste que sam a produit parce
qu'il a terminé ce dessin des ses envies
noir j'ai vraiment eu l'impression que
c'était un mauvais présage pourtant pas
superstitieuse et c'était très peu de
temps dans sa mort c'était en fait le
printemps avant son dessin du fait qu'il
n'a pas su véritablement sa maladie il
mettait ça sur le compte de la
vieillesse et c'est important pour lui
parce que si d'ailleurs je lis je les
écris quand le professeur m'a dit est ce
que vous croyez qu'on peut lui dire la
maladie jadis surtout pas il n'aurait
pas accepté
il aurait pas que c'était hélas il y
avait quand même toujours cette
espérance bon de dire c'est la
vieillesse
et puis alors on lui disait avec mont
cascades les eaux ont souffert
comprenez elle a finalement s'accrocher
il y croyait qu'il croyait et à
l'organiser toujours j'ai tellement eu
de bonheur que je n'ai pas le droit de
me plaindre
il trouvait normal d'avoir des
rhumatismes de l'arthrose et c'est nous
en connaissions malheureusement la
nature particulier il n'y a jamais fait
illusion
si ce n'est
quand je suis allé voir la dernière fois
ouaddou et qui m'a dit je suis fatigué
et suis en train de dessiner la fiche
pour la fête des potiers vision actuelle
tant elle a eu lieu il ya un mois la
fête des potiers
c'est pour l'année prochaine pour la
première fois il m'a répondu l'année
prochaine je ne serai plus là donc il
faut que je pense il n'a pas eu le temps
de finir par s
[Musique]
en
oh
on
[Musique]
et c'est quand il a vu qu'il peut pas
partir en tournée qui sait résoudre ça
vraiment quand il m'a téléphoné en
disant tu sais je viens d'apprendre par
pas en tournée cet été pour lui les
effondrements set c'était sa vie c'était
c'est bien sûr il aimait le cinéma mais
sa vie cet été
[Musique]
une fois de plus cocteau ne s'était pas
trompé toutes les qualités qui lui a
prêté
il les avait quand il l'appelait son âge
mais je crois qu'ils se trompent pas
mais j'ai comme un un regret je veux
dire quand on me demande si j'ai des
regrets dans la vie je dis non
j'ai jamais eu de regret mais j'ai quand
même un regret c'est de ne pas m'être
contenter d'être le serviteur de couteau
une coup et j'ai voulu être jean marais
et de c'était de la prétention de
l'orgueil de du cabotinage bon j'ai
voulu être jamais et je suis devenu jean
marais mais je trouve qu'une vie était
assez ramper à être son serviteur tout
simplement
jean marais marcher la tête haute il
pouvait
car comme il le disait
la plus belle crèmes de beauté c'est la
bonne conscience
et il est un pays où l'on sait
[Applaudissements]
et aux personnes des méchants
[Musique]
au loup ni les graves problèmes
mais de savoir si l'un pas
mieux qu'un champ
[Musique]
c'est ce tte là
j'habite
[Musique]
j'habite à
là le jeu
salle les uns
les rythmes
on n'a pas besoin de permis
pour être admis
j
[Musique]
d co 2
ah non mais
avant bon
[Musique]
si vous demandez aux
ou c'est trop bas
l' endroit
avec
la dca suivre tout droit
pour être roi
[Musique]
moi je le suis et nous le sommes
quoi chez soi tout
l'est
jeunes femmes et jeunes
[Musique]
sont les rois et sont les valets locaux
tous
il a la mine
pelé d'ortie et plus
de chardons
au lieu d'un dessinée
jamais
accepte de les dents
[Musique]
ninon
[Applaudissements]
dormir
mais sans du train
et surtout je vous le conseille
né à 2
[Musique]